hi there steve kaufman here i'm back in
vancouver
um
back into the cold although it's not
that cold not as cold as the rest of
canada
and uh today i want to talk about
holistic learning versus structured
learning or the role of explanations
in language learning and remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
and the reason i want to do that is i've
i've come back now from palm springs
when i was in palm springs all i had was
my ipad
and iphone and link
so i was struggling to read our many
stories
um you know initially i learned the uh
the arabic
letters
and
largely well first of all because i
downloaded lists from the internet which
showed their forms you know the
standalone form and then
the form of the letters at the beginning
the middle and at the end of a word
and then i started reading referring to
these lists listening to the text to
speech listening to the human voice
telling these stories and just
struggling to sort of absorb the
language and and sort of
not knowing really initially
certainly no sense of of uh you know
endings masculine feminine uh
cases any grammatical structure
whatsoever just dealing with words and
meaning
and i did that a because i didn't have
anything else down there with me
i had i wasn't planning on starting into
arabic it's just that i decided all of a
sudden to do it
so once i came back to vancouver
yesterday i had
because whenever i see interesting books
i buy them so i had previously bought a
book called
easy arabic grammar
and a book called arabic verbs now both
of these books have a tremendous
advantage
in so far as i'm concerned because
they're very small
i like grammar books that are small i
don't like getting deep into stuff full
of explanations and full of drills
so that's one thing so now
i've started this book and as i go
through it
i see explanations of things that i have
already encountered
and therefore i'm able to make sense of
them and when they talk about feminine
nouns that ends and i can't remember
what it was
i can't remember it doesn't matter i see
it it relates to something that i know
it clarifies something that i've been
you know anxious to learn about
and uh i i again i understand there are
issues with arabic verbs
and i will after i finish my easy arabic
grammar i'll get into arabic verbs then
i take all of this explanation without
trying to remember anything
and certainly without doing any of the
exercises these books are full of
exercises i don't do them i can't get
myself to do them
i
will go back into my sort of
holistic listening and reading
uh armed with a little better sense of
what's happening and start to notice a
few more things
and then i'll forget some of the stuff
that was in these books and i go back
and i refer to that again and then i go
back to my listening and reading i think
in doing that perhaps some of the
vocabulary will start to click in okay
the same is true with the writing system
um
i was recommended the book by judith
meyer
on
arabic writing so i bought it from
amazon
and i will do a review of it later on
but it just so happened that judith
contacted me and said here i'll send you
a free copy so i got a ebook version
free
and i started going through it and it is
also very good in terms of its
explanation
of the
arabic letters it has a number of neat
things in there for example
uh because it's difficult to identify uh
these arabic letters in the middle of
the word she has
with each letter that she introduces she
has a little highlight
showing that letter in the middle of a
word so you're given a
bunch of text
and you're asked to identify where this
little
letter shows up
so you
put a little or she has put little
yellow markers when it's at the
beginning of the word the middle of the
word or at the end of a word
and then you know asks the reader to do
the same well i'm not i don't do
exercise so i don't do that but it helps
it's all little these little bits and
pieces of explanation so her book
contains a bunch of explanation i only
had a brief look at it so i can't
comment but my feeling there again is
that i am glad that i struggled
on my own and identified sort of the
problems that i have there's always the
same little guy that looks like an eye
which actually is could be an n could be
a d depending on where but anytime i see
something like this with a dot on it
my brain says it's an i because in engl
or in the latin alphabet it's an i
and i know that
regardless of explanations
that until my brain is used to seeing
that in
many many many contexts where it
actually has a value n or the value
the
i can't remember that well it doesn't
matter i have to see it so many many
times
that that kind of holistic process
of forcing the brain to get used to a
new pattern that relates to another
language that until that starts to
happen it's going to be a long time it's
the same with with the cyrillic alphabet
of course i know that the what we
recognize as a p
in english has the value r in cyrillic
or for that matter in greek uh it took
me the longest time in russian i underst
i knew that that was a an r sound but
when you're reading
even i go to look something up in the
dictionary i look up under p
i think it's a p
so it's not explanations as i've said
many times it's like i always it's like
as i say the third person singular of
the present tense in english most people
know
that it takes an s
he goes she goes
and yet so many people say he go she go
so it just takes a lot of getting used
to
so
however so what my point is this and and
judith
said to me she said i know that you and
some other people learn holistically i
can't do that says judith of herself i
need to be structured i need to be
focused one step at a time i learn this
and then i learn that and i don't feel
happy unless i've totally understood
a before i can move on to b i i presume
that's what judith meant i'm maybe
putting words
in her mouth but the point is this out
there
those of you who are watching are you
holistic learners
or
structured learners and maybe we can
have a little poll on it so we'll put
the uh put the poll uh
poll uh a link up here if you want to
tell us
what kind of a learner you are or any
comments you might have
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you